democrats to begin our discussions but
we are committed
that by the end of this month make sure
that before the enhanced unemployment
insurance
expires that we pass legislation so that
we can
protect americans that are unemployed
and we've said the number one issue is
we have to fix the technical effects on
enhanced unemployment
we're going to make sure that we don't
pay people more money to stay home than
go to work we want to make sure that
people who can go to work safely can do
so we'll have tax credits that
incentivize businesses to bring people
back to work
we'll have tax credits for pp e for safe
work environment
and we're going to have big incentives
money to the states for
education for schools that can open
safely and and do education so these are
the priorities as well as liability
protection we want to make sure that
frivolous lawsuits
don't prevent schools universities and
businesses
from reopening okay mike
well mr president i just want to i want
to say how much we appreciate
the leadership in the house and senate
today's conversation is a continuation
of your commitment to do whatever it
takes to get the american people
american businesses and communities
through this very
challenging time the outbreaks across
the sun belt
are serious but because of the support
that we've had
from frankly leaders in both political
parties in the congress of the united
states
we're meeting this moment with expanded
testing
personal protective equipment and as you
said mr president
with the development and distribution of
therapeutics and a rapid development
of vaccines that will all continue but
it's important that the congress come
together
and and provide additional resources
for families that have been impacted
businesses that have been impacted
uh we'll make sure our health care
workers and our states have the
resources that they need
uh but also mr president we're going to
continue
to advance policies that will make it
possible for us to open up america again
and open up
america's schools and i look forward i
know as you do
and working with the leaders who have
gathered here
and members of congress in both
political parties to deliver
another important element of a recovery
package that will
will keep on working until we bring our
country all the way back and reach that
day that
we someday put this coronavirus in the
past okay
yeah tomorrow begins the process of
socializing
what we've been discussing with the
administration over the last two weeks
with our members and uh if you're
looking for
a theme here thank liability protection
for those who've
been trying to deal with the pandemic
we don't need an epidemic of lawsuits on
the heels of the pandemic we're already
struggling with kids in school
jobs and healthcare to be the theme of
the proposal
that we hope to come together and
present to our republicans
and then as the secretary of the
treasury negate obviously you can't
pass the bill in the senate without the
democrats we'll again talk to them as
well
yes uh i mean just to sum up what we're
looking at
if you're sitting in the home and you're
concerned that you don't have a job
we want to make sure you're able to come
back we don't think any federal money
should be spent that gives you
disincentive to work we want to make
sure we have incentives to keep going
for those small businesses we'll make
sure you can stay open
you want to make sure your kids can go
back to school but go back safely not
just for the children but for the
teachers as well
we continue to make strides to make sure
we get to a vaccine
we find a cure for this virus that we
did not invite that came to a foreign
land
and i think that's the focus that we
have to be a part of
rich talks about and i think it's
fundamental not just for schools but for
any businesses striving whether they can
open back up or not
they should not have an attack from any
lawsuits
we need to give the protection that we
rebuild restore
and redo this country to where we were
before i know we can do it
together that's why we're working here
we'll be reaching out to the democrats
and i hope for that moment in time
to put politics aside that we look at
one nation
that we don't sit back inside of a rule
within a senate
that a minority denies the ability to
have this debate that denies the ability
to help america unite and solve this
problem once and for all
we are making great strides when it
comes to therapies
what this warp speed history will write
about this
when we get to the moment in time that
we have this vaccine don't write about
how fast it would
and no other country could do what we
did because the ingenuity of this nation
and that's the focus of what we're
trying to do the safety of this country
for our students for our teachers and
for our businesses that we're back to
work again
stronger and safer and more united it
came from
china it should have never been allowed
to get out they could have stopped it
they could have stopped it easily they
chose not to and we'll have further
reports on that
but it came from china they could have
stopped it they didn't they stopped it
from going into china but they didn't
stop it from going
to the rest of the world it didn't stop
it from going to europe
to us they should have stopped it they
could have stopped it
they weren't transparent at all they
were the opposite it's not good
i spoke with the president of france as
well
and i spoke with uh i spoke with the
president of egypt and we had a very
very good
conversation both of us and uh all of us
and all of us together i've had many
conversations with
leaders all over the world over the
weekend and
over the last couple of weeks in
particular and this is a
pandemic that is flaring up all over the
place the country so they were in good
shape
and then all of a sudden they had a big
flare-up
i see that over the weekend i guess on
friday there was a record worldwide
number
of death worldwide because when you
watch
the news the local news and you see it
and it's uh
it's like all about the united states i
never like to talk about what's going on
in the world
but you look at mexico brazil
many countries in europe many all over
russia
russia's got a tremendous problem it's
uh what's going on is terrible it's
terrible but this is a worldwide problem
and we're helping the world with
ventilators we're helping a lot of
countries they don't have ventilators
and we're sending thousands of
ventilators to different countries but
i do want people to understand it's a
worldwide problem caused by china
but it's a worldwide problem countries
are going through hell
and it's going to we're going to give
you a lot of
briefings in the next week and over the
next few weeks as to i think it's very
important to do with the vaccines and
the therapeutics
i think i'm going to bring some of the
great companies that are working and
very successfully in the past have
worked on these things and they're going
to tell you
very specifically what they're doing and
how they're doing
but we think we're doing very well in
that regard those two
items i think frankly therapeutic i like
almost better at this point you go in
and you make people better now we have
had some very good luck with rendissevir
that's been
successful and others have been uh
successful the plasma has been
successful
but we are we're really coming up with
some very good answers being
they are all over the world they're
working and we're working very closely
all over the world on the back seats and
the therapeutics so
we're going to have some of the heads of
these great companies coming in
johnson johnson is doing very well
in particular they seem to be doing very
well but
numerous are doing very well it's
something that i really feel
certain because you can never use
totally certain but pretty
damn certain that they're going to have
the vaccine they're going to have
therapeutics and it's going to start
taking place very shortly
and that will be a great thing for the
world that would be a great thing but
this is happening all over the world
not just the united states and uh
it's a tough one very tough very sad
when you see the death
it's all death that could could have
been stopped by china
if they wanted to stop it they could
have stopped it okay thank you very much
all right guys
thanks guys guys let's go come on guys
guys
let's go john let's go come on guys
how important is the payroll tax cut i
think it's very important i think it's a
very important thing is we're good
uh it's been proven to be successful
it's uh
a big saving for the people it's a
tremendous saving and i think it's an
incentive for
companies to hire the workers back and
to keep their workers the payroll tax
cut for me is very important
we're working on that and i don't think
there's too much dispute as to
uh the level of importance yeah it's a
very important thing okay
that's one of many elements we're
discussing we're discussing
uh probably a total of 10 different
elements but payroll tax cuts are very
important
oh absolutely no i think
i think hopefully we'll get there but
we're talking about a lot of things not
just the
feral tests
well we had very successful briefings i
was doing them
and we had a lot of people watching
record numbers watching in the history
of cable television television there's
never been anything like
it and we were doing very well
and i thought it would be sort of
automatic and a lot of
a lot of positive things were happening
and frankly a lot of the country is
doing well a lot of people don't say as
you understand but we have had this big
flare-up
in florida texas a couple of other
places
and so i think what we're going to do
is i'll get involved and we'll start
doing briefings whether it's this
afternoon or tomorrow probably
tomorrow and i'll do briefings and part
of the briefing i think much more so
than last time because last time we were
nowhere with vaccines or therapeutics
and let's say that ended six weeks ago
we'll start them again
and i think it's a great way to get
information out to the public
as to where we are with the vaccines
with the therapeutics and generally
speaking where we are
and so i think we'll start that probably
starting tomorrow i'll do it at
five o'clock like we were doing we had a
good slot
and a lot of people were watching and
that's a good thing i think that kaley
will continue hers at 11 o'clock
just like they were and i'll be
discussing
the as i call it the china virus the
china plague
i'll be discussing it and i'll also be
discussing perhaps some other things but
you know we're doing very well in so
many different ways but unfortunately uh
this is something that's very tough but
we're gonna get it solved and i think
we're gonna get it solved in
numerous ways but the two best would be
vaccines and therapeutics
so we'll be having this portland and
other
cities that are experiencing violence
yes there was a report out this morning
that
you're considering sending 175 federal
troops to these cities to help local law
enforcement can you fill us in
it depends on what your definition of
troops is we're sending law enforcement
portland was totally out of control the
democrats the liberal democrats running
the place had no idea what they were
doing
they were ripping down for 51 days
ripping down that city
destroying the city looting it the level
of
corruption and what was going on there
is incredible
and then the governor comes oh we don't
need any help how about chicago
i read the numbers were many people
killed over the weekend we're looking at
chicago too we're looking at new york
look at what's going on all run by
democrats all run by very liberal
democrats
all run really by radical left but
we can't let this happen to the cities
new york was up 348 percent the crime
wave
so the governor has to do something
about it and if the governor is not
going to do something about it we'll do
something about it but what's happening
in new york
a place i love i love new york and look
at what's going on over there
the woman who was shot because she said
could you please not
light off firecrackers and they turned
around shot her eight times and she died
that's not our civilization that's not
about us
and then the police are afraid to do
anything i know new york very well i
know the police very well
new york's finest and the fact is
they're restricted from doing anything
they can't do anything well i'm gonna do
something that i can tell you
because we're not gonna let new york and
chicago and philadelphia detroit
and baltimore and all of these
oakland is a mess we're not going to let
this happen in our country
all run by liberal democrats
we're going to have more federal law
enforcement that i can tell you in
portland
they've done a fantastic job they've
been there three days
and they really have done a fantastic
job in a very short period of time no
problem
they grab them a lot of people in jail
they're leaders these are anarchists
these are not protesters
people say protesters these people are
anarchists
these are people that hate our country
and we're not going to let it go
forward and i'll tell you what the
governor and the mayor
and the senators out there they're
afraid of these people
that's the reason they don't want us to
help them they're afraid i really
believe they're actually
maybe even physically afraid of these
people
because what they're doing is incredible
we didn't just go there this wasn't like
it started right away
we went there after 51 days we said
we can't let that happen anymore but
these are anarchists
and the politicians out there yes
they're weak
but they're afraid of these people
they're actually afraid of these people
and that's why they say
we don't want the federal government
helping how about chicago
would you say they need help after this
weekend do you know the numbers did you
hear the numbers
many many shot many many killed
many i'm not talking about one two
was it 18 people killed i think more
than that
and you ended up over the summer this is
worse than afghanistan
by far this is worse than anything
anyone's ever seen
all run by the same liberal democrats
and you know what if biden got in that
would be true for the country
the whole country would go to hell and
we're not going to let it go to hell
thank you very much all right guys let's
go guys
come on guys hey let's go
you
you